not many people feeling patriotic in joe
biden's america this fourth of july and
it's really no wonder with an
out-of-touch white house telling
americans suffering to just suck it up
according to a new fox news poll just 39
percent of americans are proud of where
the country is today which is down 12
points from a 2017
and a whopping 30 points since 2011. it
marks the first time a majority feels
disappointed in this country
and as americans feel the heat from
raging inflation and
astronomical gas prices the white house
is doubling down on their deal with it
philosophy
how long is it fair to expect american
drivers and drivers around the world to
pay that premium for this war
as long as it takes so russia cannot in
fact
defeat ukraine and move beyond ukraine
this is a critical critical position for
the world well what do you say to those
families who say listen we can't afford
to pay 485 a gallon for months if not
years this is just not sustainable this
is about the future of the liberal world
order and we have to stand firm and if
people think we're on the wrong track
the white house thinks you just need to
be reminded how awesome things really
are
85 percent of u.s adults say the country
is on the wrong track 85 percent that's
up from 68 percent in march it appears
that increasingly the american people do
not approve of what this white house is
doing but these are uncertain times and
when prices are high uh people are
understandably frustrating we have and
also remind the american people that
even as we go through this challenging
period even as we move through this
transition
we also have made historic economic
progress
you know
joey that guy dees the economic council
director i mean when he points to the
fact that you know
the fact that the majority of americans
feel disappointed in the country right
now he says you know they they just are
not looking at how great the economy is
this guy is in charge of the economic
council for the white house you know if
one more person on this network says
it's the economy stupid i'm gonna i'm
gonna lose it like i hear it all day on
every on every network that's where
americans are and i believe that's true
when it comes to our politicians but
when we talk about being disappointed in
this country i think it's cultural i
think the left looks at our country and
they see our prosperity as a symbol of
oppression centuries of oppression they
see the rejection of crt or the supreme
court decision on roe versus wade and
they say we're still under the thumb
it's the it's the the midwives tale or
whatever that's called the right looks
at world culture
the right looks at crt they look at walt
culture and they see the decay of what
makes this country great to them and to
an extent they're kind of both right not
that i believe that something uh
something like what the left talks about
is oppression but there was before the
societal expectation of just presenting
yourself and speaking respectfully and
making a point without having to glue
yourself to something and and the right
sees the decay of that as losing what
makes us great so both sides especially
through our political representatives
that play into this see us in a really
bad place but the question uh degan
don't you think the question is how they
feel about the country today and and 85
percent of the people think we're headed
in the wrong direction so it's it's
pretty clear how they feel about the
country is that different from whether
or not they love the country
it does play into it because
the country has gone in a horrible
direction under biden incorporated by
any and every metric it's worse than
when biden took office biden was
supposed to be like a pallet cleanser
like a
champagne sorbet instead he's like an
old crab cake that you paid five
thousand dollars for it leaves a bad
taste in your mouth and you're probably
going to get food poisoning from it
to joey's point though
the liberal default when at about being
a proud american is not being proud the
default for conservatives historically
is you are proud
and you this bears out in the numbers
where among
republicans the being american pride has
fallen by 28 points since um 2017 and
then 21 points among independents and
that is because of the direction of the
country like when you say
for republicans yeah we're we're out at
walmart or the wawa buying a koozie
you know with proud american on it and
that's right and for liberals that you
know that just get you asked them oh are
you um proud of the united states and
they go yeah it's fine
yeah
so it's still even that's what jessica
said in the green room
but you know jessica when the president
says that the americans should expect to
continue to pay these high prices high
gas prices and i i expect the food
prices and inflation and everything else
until uh russia is is defeated in
ukraine what if russia's never defeated
in ukraine well that's increasingly what
people who used to be in the military
and on air are commenting are saying
that i went to a talk recently with
admiral mcraven and he said unless we
kind of proverbial you know what or get
off the pot we're just going to be stuck
in this place for a very long time and
the expectation is that yes putin
thought originally i can do this in 30
days now that he knows that that's not
possible he can wait it out for the rest
of time yeah i mean he can just stand
there and yes we we have made bigger
moves and when we sent in new missile
systems this week that should change the
game a little bit but putin has nothing
but time and we don't the messaging on
this has been extremely poor everybody
understands that we are part of a global
economy that's not a hard concept for
folks to understand but when it seems
like you don't have a choice
in terms of
what you are paying for that's something
that rubs people the wrong way because i
think if you said oh we could scale back
a little bit or maybe you know put a few
troops on the ground or build up and
poland for instance and get you a dollar
off your gas bill i think that people
would say generally speaking i want a
dollar off my gas bill since they have
tethered those things so closely
together which i actually don't think is
the reason that this is happening on the
proud american front i think dagan is
right that the way that liberals and
conservatives talk about patriotism is
just fundamentally different i don't
think that it means that we actually
love the country any differently this
trend did start in 2017 that includes
three years of the trump era this is not
just biden walked into into office and
suddenly everyone decided that we hate
it here um but the way that folks talk
about this is important to take into
account uh when evaluating our varying
degrees of love for america uh you know
greg
one of the the the lines that really
concerned me was when adees i think it's
diese again the economic council guy
says
um you know the future of the liberal
world order is at stake
do we elect this guy to change the
future of the liberal world order joe
biden it's actually
this is a really big deal but i first
i'm just so tired of hearing you people
talking about where is the pride in
america we just had a full month
we just had a full month of pride you
guys oh wait that wasn't about being an
american
that was about sexual orientation you
could do that for a month
you better do that for a month your
company better set emails on that for a
month but if you talk about patriotism
that's so old school old-fashioned what
a scary fast trip from america first
to america last
that liberal
world order phrase used to be something
you might hear somebody on infomercial
say i'm not i'm sorry infowars say but
it's actually was said it was actually
said out loud that one sound bite should
be in every commercial for every
republican campaign you should play that
liberal world order uh uh blurb to
truckers to parents buying food to
delivery workers because it's this kind
of it's one of the biggest like reveals
in history in political history they're
saying yeah you know what
the greater good mean the greater global
good
means your suffering doesn't matter true
it's very stalinist people will die but
you got to break some eggs to make an
omelet of course you never see the
omelet all you see are the broken eggs
it's a very honest comment and i and
we're learning that the administration
just isn't that into us
being america's so what is the
democratic party offering to people
you're either woke or you're broke right
woke destroys the internal organs of a
country everybody's fighting each other
then you have the new world order which
is the external breakdown we're fighting
a war thousands of miles away right and
that trumps our gas prices we're willing
to accept perhaps world famine even
in our own local misery for a war that
won't end because both sides according
to both sides are winning and we're fun
for fueling this war and billions and
billions of dollars and there is a price
for everything including war which is
why trump had it right which is you
drill drill drill you become energy
independent so international turmoil has
no effect on you but you can't have it
both ways you can't want cheap oil and
then go to war against the people that
supply the the oil although it's only
eight or nine percent it's not a problem
for us it's a european problem yes but
well i mean what well biden clearly says
it's a problem for us
that's his excuse yes uh but but biden
gave them the waiver for nordstrom and
while he shut down the american uh oil
and gas so i mean it it's real it's the
whole thing is a frightening situation
yeah go ask texas about the liberal
world yes
you have to understand this is that is
something that is a gift from heaven
yeah that they said it yeah that they
actually came out and said it